c'est la scène qu'on voit le plus dans
le métro de montréal n'est pas sage et
tête baissée fixant leur téléphone
cellulaire
les stations mont joli carré angrignon à
l'ouest de la ligne verte étaient les
dernières à ne pas offrir de réseaux
mobiles depuis sept semaines
elles sont branchés le métro de montréal
avec ses 71 km de tunnels offre
aujourd'hui le plus important réseau
numérique intérieur au canada certains
comment retrouver le réseau dans le
métro jusqu'à d'athlètes et avait
longtemps que de l eau pas de réseau ces
temps passés depuis le branchement des
premières stations un chantier complexe
car les travaux devaient se faire de
nuit quand le métro est arrêté et ne
durait que deux heures et demie chaque
fois ça avant à chaque station telus
bell rogers et vidéotron se sont
partagés la facture de 50 millions de
dollars
c'est eux qui ont fait les travaux nous
on a choisi d'aller avec un cadre indien
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus longue
chaque ouverture et s'il a agi comme une
petite atteint
dans des mini
c'est ça qui fait que le signal est
vraiment star
le métro offre un réseau 4g lte est et
n'a pas de bonnes oreilles faille un
passager avec un simple ipad ou qui n'a
pas de forfait avec telus bell rogers ou
vidéotron ne peut donc pas aller sur
internet n'a d'autres villes vous allez
avoir un réseau eye-fi sur le quai rien
dans le tunnel ici on est capable de
partir de côte vertu et d'écouter le
hockey en se rendant au centre-ville en
direct sans coupure avec une connexion
est un signal en haute définition
le réseau pourrait un jour passer aux 5
g une piste intéressante à étudier dit
la st1 ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada m'ont rien